Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Pop Goes
Now, I know it's been a while since the last time, I played this
And a lot of you probably thought that I was just gonna abandon, and not finish it
Just like I did with, Five Nights at Candy's 3
Well, guess what, I ain't gonna do that!
I'm gonna finish this!
Probably not, in this one episode, because it's been a long time since the last time I played
--which means that, I've forgotten pretty much all the mechanics
And then I plan to go back and finish five nights at candy's 3
which I meant to do a long time ago
And then I always get sidetracked, but I wanna
beeeeee~~
the very best like no one ever
waaaaaas~~
Alright, how the f- I'm gonna die like I know I'm gonna die like right away. So that's just a given Oh
helloooo
All Right see ya
Cuz I scare him away like that. You know, okay, which I don't remember which rooms go to which place
So let's just let's just get it over with
aye yi yi
hiii!
Don't do that
STOP
S T O P
Why what do I just not get to look over there the relaxing view up the windows it's not gonna happen for me, okay?
I see how it is. They've probably already moved way out ah I should panic
I know I should I've completely forgotten how to play I am going to die
Oh It's just it's just evident. Okay, Green got it called it. Oh boy. I'm dead
I'm do- there's that guy with the thing that I needed him not to take that's okay
I can I can survive a little bit, I guess
Oh frick oh no, where are they where are they oh?
Well, that's a sound to my left
Well, I see ya see ya, dude. Well. I'm surprised. I'm not dead he's going to the art room
What are you gonna do in the art room? Huh? Which one's the art room again? dude. I can't even remember
Shut it down! What are you gonna do about it? Nothing? I'm already missing things. Oh man. Why is the game lagging?
*stupid ass Windows crashing*
OOOOHHHHHHH
It crashed?????
NOOOOOO
Shitty tits let's try that again shall we and this time hopefully not suck nearly as much as I just did
Ahhhhh
What if I scream at you? Huh? How do you uh?
wh-i-just ahHHH
Where's the birth oh is that the birthday oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no, how did I miss that?
Ah, I did get them. He wants to go to the aah. I shouldn't be afraid. I'm not afraid of you
I'm stronger than you are
uuuggghhh
Why am I pointing my finger like this? I've just got my finger out like this permanently no!!
That's a no no, mr. Weasel whoa! okay, all right? Where's he gonna go next I should check this room huh that's important.
No ah
cerulean got it nailed ah
STOP Oh god. I'm such an idiot. I'm gonna put my finger down you're still there
Hi! Okay, see ya Wow alright. Seriously, dude go away
oh. OOOOHHHH I SHUT IT DOWN
DID I GET IT?
I Thought I could just look at you. That's what I thought I could do just have a nice relaxing looky-loo oh
don't
Hi, how's it going friend that that's him? I saw did I see him maybe I saw him. They're still there, so that's nice
ooh
NOOOOOO
I got the wrong one and
Now I'm gonna panic what a lovely view of you what the fuck was that?
red fire passion red
That was weird that was weird
Oh my power almost went out
Are you still back there? Okay? You're still
God dammit You a sack of shit. Don't do that to me. Uh you're gonna go in the the side room or wherever
That is I don't even know I don't remember what the cameras placed. I don't know where remember where anything is
I don't know what I'm doing. I'm at a complete loss. I'm at a standstill nO!
ugh
You still there okay? You're still there. They're still there. I'm still here everyone's fine
There's really no reason to panic. I don't remember which room was that it was that one. No that was a balloon. Oh
I saw I thought awwwww ahh ahhhhhhhhh
*laughs*
Oh
God damn it. I'm never gonna be able to get through this. I'm barely 1 a.m. in
I forgot that this game also takes a long-ass time
To get through it. I got to get my bearings together, and Oh I'v- hi friend. How you doing
how you doing okay alright
See you have a good day at school. Rrrred you got it passion fire. I give it I feel it
I feel it for you <3
Ah they're just going in the vents good good good. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good ghanoush, baba
Ganoush you stop you look in the vents not there yet, but you're gonna be there
You're about to be there who hey wait no
Stop that you're bad bad squirrels
Bad where'd you go? Oh no invent look vent look? Oh?
Heat ok now the heat phase has started, and I just need to not let them get heated
No, not that this that and that and heat there
No! ):<
Stop looking at me funny. I hate this I hate this Oh, Oh God
I wasn't watching vent heat what where who huh? What huh? Oh did I get it?
I don't know if I got it, I'm panicking did I get it?
I Think I got it. Oh shit the dye the friggin Heat oh
ugh
Hello pink, okay alright
oooohhhhh
who lied to me?? YOU LIED TO ME!
HEY STOP
No Nuh uh
Oh god the heat heeeeeaaat you get another piece, okay?
I think he did I think he funcle' he did oh god damn it ah heat
ugh
Okay, I can't let him go again. I've got three more hours to not let him
Go which is perfectly easy, then I can totally do that and I won't fail. Ho what happened where you where you okay?
You're going on the birthday room. I know I know that's the birthday right okay?
Heat no heat birthday room okay? Ah no and look here
Oh red and blam and look BAM. Okay. Yeah heat delivered
No! okay, I still got that in my brain, I cannot believe I got that in my brain if I can control it there
Then I might still have a chance
uuughhhhhh
That must be the last one he needs because he's gonna keep going there because all the parts
They aren't randomly screwing him out there. They're very specific
to the room that which they are in
So if I'm able to get that under way then I should be okay, right?
No, I said, no to you. Okay, so the Badgers gonna be the next red ok bonk and you're fine
Okay howdy?
Goody, shuddhi downy venti wenti heaty weaty. Okay so far so goo. Okay, 4:00 a.m.. That's good
Hey 4 a.m's a fun time for me heat
Ahhhhhh
Sorry I just scream randomly you did it again goddamn. He's very into that one part
He's very very persistent about that one
Okay, there wasn't anything else that I needed to worry about right
No heat ready and heat okay, so far so goo
And red and bunk and outie and I'm backie because he's he's probably yeah, I called that one
Shutti Downey heaty bami, okay. It's a good rhythm. It's a good rhythm nope. Oh god. He snuck in there
ahhhh
It's like every ten seconds on the dot
Buck got you right on your noggin pop goes the weasel whoo. That's why it's called that ha ha ha
aye yi yi
5 a.m.. We can do this we can do this shut it down
Okay all right easy peasy heaty weaty mean it. I mean it once you got it down to like the last piece. It's the
Puzzle can't be completed if he doesn't get the last piece. Oh, oh oh god. Oh god. Oh god
Oh god pink that this shut down. Oh, no that was too early. Oh, no oh, no. Did I goof it
Please tell me I didn't goof it oh
Can you get that if?
Okay, I'm good, okay
HEY! :D
YES!
God that was STRESSFUL
Oh
Why was that so stressful?
hnnnnggg
I don't like it. Okay. Do I get a crawl through the creepy?
oooohhhh
whaaaaaaaaaaaaatttttttt
wha?
Well okay
Okay
So I'm guessing that custom night
Probably has some sort of truth to it that it's talking about let me check out the extras first characters
Okay
Species least weasel why is he least weasel? green? pop goes the weasel is a singer and leader of pop goes
Pizzeria band his design is inspired by the least weasel his hat was purchased from an auction and originally
ha ha ha
Originally belonged to freddy fazbear of course it did European badger power color yellow Blake the Badgers the mechanic and help for hello
helper of pop goes pizzeria
It's a sign is inspired by the European badger his palms have magnetic pads that help them hold weasel wear phones and do
other things
very
Scary all right species gray squirrel power color blue Sarah the squirrel is the bassist of the Pops goes
pizzeria band her designs inspired by the grey squirrel
She isn't directly connected to weasel wear, but will help pop goes out on tasks. He is set
Okay
red squirrel power color pink
Saffron the squirrels the guitarist of the pop goes pizzeria band her design is inspired by the red squirrel her
Programming has forced her to become an exact copy of her sister
Forced her? hm..weird carrion crow oh so friendly ah so family-oriented
oh
No kid would have nightmares about that thing
Stone the crows a sign older who stays outside the Bob goes pizzeria his design is inspired by the carrion crow stone isn't connected to
Anything at all if you see him moving you're hallucinating
oookay
Alright Okay, I see I see what's going on here. I see what's going on titty Winkle impossible mode reward okay? Oh?
Black rabbit power color white
Black rabbit is a collection of six black plastic body parts in the style of toy Bonnie
Black rabbits parts are untreated and unpainted causing them to crumble to powder overnight pop-goes will try to build black rabbit
No matter. What find out why.
I Don't wanna. I don't wanna
oh?
Oh gemstone find the truth
alright
Okay, can't get those. Nope nope nope nope nope okay alright weird
huh
ew...
I Do not like that
Hmm nope don't like looking at that at all
Nope don't like that no no no no don't like that. I'm gonna go away from that okay. That was horrifying. Alright.
[Scary music picks up]
[Sounds like Wilford.] Don't you worry.
[Sounds like Mark/Dark] I'll get you.
[Music]
So that's it for that but as with all these five nights at Freddy's games
It never ends there, so I'm gonna take a look at custom night.
hhhnnnngg
hhhngg
Okay
hhhnnnnnggg
So I don't think that I'm gonna try to beat it on impossible mode
oohhhhh
ahhhh
ohhh
ahhhhh (stop making weird noises this is hard)
I'm gonna give it a go. I'll give it a try
But uh this isn't that good good. Good night. Good night to me, or it's a good night. And everyone's gonna get crunk?
Is that kind of good night We're looking for? well the robos
Which I am I know. I'm a robo that's obvious okay. Good. Good night. Good night. Love you. Bye birthday room, huh?
Yeah, that's not the birthday, and this is the birthday room
wha hoooooo hey whoa whoa whoa uh oh
He already got a piece out, I don't know how he got that that's all he's going into the art room
ahhhh
Oh no
oh
I oh I oh I
I got 'em!
Stop come on man. Give me a break
I'm just trying to look out the window
Stop that
Didn't even Oh God power power power. Oh the green the bunk. Oh panic okay?
HEY I just need to look man
I gotta look! sTOP
I Gotta look, just let me look at you. You're so pretty
Anyone ever tell you that no. Where are the?
Where are the squirrels? Oh?
God didn't they know I'm king of them oh I'm boned Oh
*Sudden robot hand*
HEY OHHHHHH NOOOOOOO
Oh, I welp there I go oh
*sigh*
ow my brain
ugh
owie
oof
oh the thingy mabobber Okay? So that's incredibly difficult?
I'm not gonna do that so this has been an interesting experience. I really liked it
The only problem is I didn't like it enough to dive super deep into the lore
And this is probably gonna sound like I'm being critical about the game, but like I said
I like the game the only problem is I feel like too much
Was left up to be discovered in the story
Because I think they were trying to emulate the fact that five nights at freddy's had a lot of
Environmental storytelling, and that's great because it did
But but the thing about this game is it drives a lot off of the five nights at freddy's lore, so I go into it
feeling already
familiar with the scenario
That I don't notice the things that are out of place and again. I don't want to be hyper critical about this. I actually enjoyed
the game
But it didn't draw me in the same way as like joy of creation did which took the characters yes and inspiration from the main
Game, but it crafted this completely new
Narrative in a different way and also like the gameplay mechanics was obviously different, and and I didn't feel as scared
Going into this one.
I Felt panicked, but not scared. You know what I mean like the enemies didn't exactly
draw me in into curiosity of what they were or who they were or
Terrify me in the same way as the lovable characters in five nights at Freddy's did or the horrifying characters that joy of creation did now again
I don't want to compare. I'm not comparing things
I'm using things as examples to just make a discussion, and I'm probably comparing it
But I don't want to like compare it unfairly this was a good game
I just didn't feel compelled to finish it completely, but I did finish it
*slams fist on desk*
Succinctly so the truth is out there if you want to find it out for yourself
I provide a link to the game in the description below, and thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down the calm
If you want to see more five nights at Freddy's fan games or stuff like that or you have a game
Suggestion of your own let me know down there in the comments as well
Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video
buh bye!!!
Reviewed by donald piper. Happy viewing!!